so a man named Rachel McKinnon just won
the women's world cycling championship
MacKinnon is a college professor in
South Carolina
he's also naturally of course he's also
from Canada originally naturally of
course no offense to Canadians and he
who's a he's a man too I should mention
that he beat a bunch of women at the
Masters track cycling World Championship
I know I don't have to tell you who won
the wet masters track cycling world
championship I mean we've all been
following it very closely but he wanted
and he of course calls himself
transgender which is how he got away
with racing a bunch of girls now the the
gentleman was was not very gracious in
victory he was even I would frankly say
not very ladylike he bragged about the
victory on Twitter he said first
transgender woman world champion ever
which is which is which is a bit like
bragging that you're the first adults to
hit 40 homeruns in t-ball you know it's
not exactly not exactly something that I
would brag about let me give you a
little bit of the LifeSite news articles
the article on this it says MacKinnon's
participation in the bracket was made
possible last year when another canadian
trans cyclist Kristin Worley won a human
rights settlement that secured a
commitment from cycling Canada that
would allow him to compete against women
but while pro LGBT groups are
celebrating the news as a milestone for
equality critics argue that letting men
who merely declare womanhood compete
with actual women is unfair because it
provides an unfair advantage to the man
but MacKinnon spent part of his Sunday
disputing the point on Twitter arguing
that quote there's no relationship in
any gender between testosterone and
performance that's his that is his
scientific view he's saying that
testosterone doesn't give you any
advantage in terms of strength or
endurance or or anything like that it's
no no not at all yeah it's it's a myth
interesting low as LifeSite News points
out MacKinnon earlier in the year in
January took a very different approach
and back then he didn't say that well I
don't have an advantage he said that the
advantage is irrelevant
because this is about
this is about my human rights this is
what he said he said by catering to
cisgender people's views that only
furthers transgender people's oppression
when it comes to extending rights to a
minority population why would we ask the
majority translation what is it who
cares what the women think this is all
about me I bet a lot of white people
were pissed off when we desegregated
sports racially and allowed black people
in but they had to deal with it and
there again you have this you have this
propensity by those in the LGBTQ camp to
constantly compare their complaints to
the historic plight of black Americans
which i think is is not only very stupid
and not only very arrogant and not only
extraordinarily historically illiterate
but it's also racist yeah I think it's
pretty racist when you've got this
privileged white man who's had
everything a life handed oh he gets
whatever he wants you know we'll even
bend and break and change the rules for
his sake whatever you want mr. McKinnon
you could have anything that's that's
what he gets
and yet he's comparing his supposed
trials and tribulations to to black
Americans who we should recall were
slaves in this country and then were
were for for a century after that were
not legally considered or allowed to be
full participants in society and he's
comparing himself as a white guy I you
know I would consider that racist
because it's so trivializes the historic
plight of black Americans and it uses
that plight in such a cynical and
emotionally manipulative and dishonest
way that I don't know what else to call
it racist all right so a few other
things to point out here first of all I
want to refer back again to the leftist
victim hierarchy or the victim pyramid
if you will and I've you know go back in
your notes because it's important you
got to go back and look at this thing
and I'm all you know I talk about this a
lot because it this helps us to kind of
sort through what's going on on the left
because we see that yeah the left makes
victims out of various different
demographic groups but they're not all
equal victims and they can't be because
what happens when the groups when all
when certain victim groups bump heads
what happens then
what happens when one victim group is
claiming that it's being victimized by
another well then what do you do it's
easy enough when any of the victim group
says that they're being victimized by by
white males but I should say by white
heterosexual cisgender males well then
it's easy enough to say well the white
heterosexual males always wrong but what
happens when you have this inter victim
conflict well that's where you have the
that's where the hierarchy comes into
play you have the you know the most
important victims at the top and then it
kind of goes down in importance from
there and you will notice that the top
victims the Alpha victims the victims
who victimization Trump's all others the
victims victim they are the people in
the LGBTQ camp and at the top of that
subgroup at the top of the top of the
top the most important of the most
important the uber victims are
transgenders they their victimization
claims Trump everybody else every time
they are the trendiest and most
important victims right now in that you
know these these things change that
could change over time and here's how
this works when a victim who is lower on
the pyramid is victimized by a victim
higher on the pyramid that is a less
important victim victimized by a more
important victim then if the less
important victim complains about being
victimized then all the sudden she is is
the is is is the bully and she has
victimized the person who's victimizing
her I know this is confusing I know I
know it's hard to keep up but this is
look this is the convoluted way that
things work on the left
don't blame you don't shoot the
messenger I'm just telling you the way
that works for them all you have to
remember is that on the victim hierarchy
you can never be victimized by someone
who is higher than you who is more
important than you
so transgenders are at the top which
means that they are victimized by
everyone in fact maybe we should think
of this as an upside-down pyramid okay
so it's an upside-down pyramid and you
have the you know the most important
victims at the bottom and that would be
that would be transgenders they're down
here at the tip and so all of the
victimization trickles down and so
they're victims of everybody all the
time even when they're stealing
Championships even when they're cheating
even when they're being absolutely
selfish bullies and narcissists they are
still the victims of everybody and then
from there you know it's you got so
you've got most important victims are
transgenders and then you've got all the
rest of the then you've got the other
then you've got the LG and B in the
acronym and the Q and the Z and all the
rest so then they're the second most
important then you have racial
minorities third most important and then
you have women so on the Left women are
kind of kind of far down in on the totem
pole really and that's why if a
transgender wants to steal a
championship from a woman the woman just
has to shut up and go along with it and
if a transgender even in this in this in
this day and age of me2 and rape culture
and consent and everything we know we've
got its emphasis on consent even now if
a man who calls himself transgender
wants to go into a locker room where a
woman is exposed and getting changed and
vulnerable and the woman is not
comfortable she has to just shut up and
take it she's not allowed to complain so
and I bring that up because that just
shows you how completely and totally the
victimization claim of the transgender
will trump the woman every time now by
the way there is also a predator or
victimizer
hierarchy a hierarchy of villains for
the leftist and of course at the very
top are straight white males and then
right below them are conservative women
and then conservative minorities are are
there as well but the crazy thing is and
this is where gets really complicated
but so the the number one the worst
bullies and predators for the left they
are white males right
straight white males but so they're at
the top of the victimizer hierarchy but
you could actually jump from the top of
that pyramid to the top of the a man can
actually make that leap a white man
could actually go for being the worst
villain in the world to being the moat
to being the martyr the most precious
victim if he simply puts on a wig and
calls himself transgender so that's an
interesting point here second thing I
want to point out is that it's often
been claimed that Christianity stifles
silent science or is afraid of science
and this claim is largely unfounded in
fact through the centuries Christians
have not only supported science but many
of the greatest scientific minds have
been Christian but it is interesting now
that so [ __ ] that's just a false a false
claim that Christianity stifle science
it doesn't but it's interesting now that
on the left you see them doing exactly
what they have always accused Christians
of doing you see them utterly rejecting
science militating against science
rejecting it cursing it saying you know
science be gone get out and get out get
away evil science and they're doing all
of that in the name of their faith
because transgenderism is a matter of
faith to say that a penis bearing
y-chromosome man can be a woman if he
feels like one is a doctrinal statement
it's a statement of dogma it has no
relation to science whatsoever that is
not a scientific statement whatsoever it
is a it is a statement of faith now
there are some Christians who believed
that the world was really
created in seven days they're wrong and
there's no reason at all to draw that
conclusion from the Bible
after all the Bible talks about days
uses the word day before the earth even
exists in fact it says day before but or
or I should say it is it says it talks
about days certainly before the Sun even
exists the Sun doesn't come into
existence in the creation story until
the four to the fourth day and even on
so called the the the first day the
earth is shapeless it's not a it's it's
it is a it is a shapeless mass in the
creation story which means that there
cannot be a day in the earthly sense yet
because in order to have an earth day
you need to have a Sun you need to have
a a spherical earth rotating on its axis
and orbiting the Sun that's that is what
an earth day is by definition and you
cannot have that in the creation story
until the fourth day so that tells us
that we're not talking about that kind
of day but anyway I don't want to get
I'm gonna get sidetracked on that but
the point is a Christian who says that
the the whole universe was created in in
seven days or six days really that is
his opinion based on faith you know
based on faith and I think based on a
bad exegesis it's so it's you know not
again as Christians that is not a
position that we have that we must hold
it is possible actually to interpret the
Genesis story in a way that comports
with with what we know about you know
what we know scientifically about the
world but it's a statement of faith
science very much for pewdie eights and
contradicts that interpretation
and you know there's no getting around
so a Christian who who sticks to that
knows that that he is you know that he's
that's that's an opinion that he's
holding totally apart from science and
it's the same sort of thing for leftist
and I'm not comparing these two views
there are different kinds of views but
it's the same sort of dynamic for
leftist and I bring this up because left
it's like to pretend that they don't
have any religious views that they don't
have any faith or anything like that but
they do because that's what this is a
leftist who talks about men who become
women and women who become men and how
they can make this transition based
entirely on their feelings that is that
is all that's pure religion that is
their religion I even saw I saw a story
a few days ago about a woman who became
a man and then became a dog okay that's
not a joke it was there's a story I saw
online a few days ago it was a woman who
identifies as a man who identifies as a
male dog so that's and now now now
here's here's the fascinating thing if
she would then identify as a male dog
who identifies as a female dog who
identifies as a female person then that
would actually close the loop and I
think it may it may in fact create a
black hole that would obliterate the
solar system I'm pretty sure which would
not necessarily be in you know an
unfortunate turn of events the point is
this is pure faith pure religion pure
dogma it's not science there is no
science and this there's no science in a
you know woman who says I'm a man and
I'm also a dog that's not science that's
pure faith science says that men have X
Y chromosomes and penises that's what
science says science knows nothing of
women trapped in man bodies it knows
nothing of that that is a very weird
kind of spiritual dualism that just is
not scientific
so there is certainly religion and faith
on the left and in fact to hold to their
religious views and their faith-based
views requires I think quite a bit more
faith than it does to believe
for instance the Bible third point
notice the incredible arrogance here I
always touched on I already touched on
this but but that's the other thing that
jumps out at you with a lot of this
identity stuff on the left
it's very self-absorbed you know it's
very it's very me me me me focused this
man has no concern for anyone else at
all it's only about what he wants what
makes him comfortable now III do think
that at the root of transgenderism there
is obviously mental disorder you know
there's obviously mental disorder going
on but I don't think it's only mental
disorder as we've seen this idea of
gender identity it's kind of expanded so
that more and more people are
discovering different and exotic and
strange fancy new forms of identity it's
become kind of a trend and so I don't
think you can explain it all just by
saying well it's all mental disorder
there's something else going on I think
there are plenty of people now who are
basically mentally stable yet they've
seen this gender identity stuff they see
the left's ideology about identity and
they choose consciously that okay I'm
gonna buy into this because there's
something about it that appeals to them
there's something about it that that
they like and I think the thing that
appeals to them about it is that it is
so self focused you know it is so
focused on the ego and on the self and
it kind of it presents the human person
as this sort of disembodied ego and
everything about the world everything
about reality everything about yourself
you get to determine to the point where
you can even determine your
your biology everything is up to you so
it turns the self into this godlike
figure and I think there's something
else too and this is a very interesting
aspect of the so called transgender
phenomenon I think what you also find is
that everybody has a deep yearning to
find identity in something transcendent
in something deeper and more profound
than simply their material right it's
it's hard for anyone to really be a
materialist you know very few people
want to say well I'm just skin and bones
that's all I am that's all there is to
me and that's it so everybody wants a
transcendent identity now for Christians
we find our transcendent identity in
Christ that's where we find primarily
first and foremost our choices try to
transcend an identity we say we're not
just skin and bones and flesh we are you
know we are children of God that's our
identity and then we would also say kind
of growing from that root I would say
well another aspect of my identity is
that I'm a husband and I'm a father so I
find my identity in all of that but on
the left well they've rejected God they
reject the family as a patriarchal
institution they reject Parenthood much
of the time because Parenthood in
fringes on their on their autonomy and
and on their ability to have a
convenient and pleasurable life so they
reject all that yeah they reject all of
the sources where they could find a
transcendent identity and they're left
only with themselves but that's not good
enough that's very depressing and so now
they have found a different sort of
transcendent identity in this kind of
spiritual superstitious faith-based idea
of transcendence transgenderism and
gender
and all that and the reason why they
prefer it to finding their identity in
God or even in family is that over here
on the left this transcendent identity
again is all self focused and it
requires no sacrifice on your part it's
all about you
whereas if you're gonna find your
identity in God well then you have to
serve God if you're gonna find your
identity and your family then you have
to serve your family they don't want to
do all that so instead I'll just serve
myself and this is where I find my
identity alright um so there's that
story here's another story I wanted to
switching gears here I wanted to call
your attention to one of the things very
quickly it's a better story
you know what we'll end on a more
positive note Kelvin Cochran was the
former fire chief of Atlanta a very
accomplished guy started as one of the
the first black firefighters in Atlanta
then he rose through the ranks to become
the fire chief and then he was hired by
Obama to run a division of FEMA and then
he was recruited back to Atlanta because
the fire department was struggling in
his absence so this was a very
sought-after guy very respected very
good at his job and then a few years ago
mr. Cochran wrote a short devotional
book about his Christian faith in which
he mentioned that the fact that marriage
according to the Bible is between a man
and a woman and I believe that this was
something that he mentioned only on like
one page of the book I'm pretty sure he
shared the book with a few people next
thing you know because he wrote this
book expressing his Christian faith
expressing a faith by the way that is
shared by millions of people in the
country next thing you know he's
suspended without pay from his job he's
forced to attend sensitivity training
and finally he's fired well he went back
and sued the city for violating his
First Amendment rights and earlier this
week in a huge victory for the First
Amendment he was awarded 1.2 million
dollars which is which is great and this
was an easy one okay should have been an
easy one anyway this is an easy case to
figure out he was fired from his job
with the government because of his
personal religious views
that is straightforward infringe you
know that is one of the more
straightforward and clear-cut cases of
First Amendment infringement that you're
ever gonna find now they did an
investigation while he was suspended
before they fired him they did an
investigation they and they found no
evidence that he had ever discriminated
against anyone even though he had outed
himself as a Christian and as someone
who believes in biblical marriage they
found no evidence that he had ever
discriminated against anyone including
homosexuals in fact he was well known
before that point for being very
inclusive very progressive in that sense
you know being inclusive and tolerant
he's a black man himself who experienced
discrimination himself very early in his
in his career so it makes sense that he
would be a tolerant and inclusive kind
of guy and you're not going to get hired
by Obama to run a federal agency or to
you know you're not gonna get hired to a
federal post by Obama unless you were
progressive and tolerant in that way or
tolerant towards different sexual
orientations anyway but he was fired
anyway they investigated him because he
declared his Christian faith they found
no evidence of discrimination said we're
gonna fire you anyway because they
didn't like his religion fired him
purely for his religious views purely
because the City Council didn't agree
with his religion and he sued and
finally he's getting 1.2 million dollars
now I think what you when you look at
this case then you look at the
masterpiece cake shop which was a
victory for Jack Phillips it was not the
full-on complete total victory that it
could have been and should have been but
it was still a victory and it was yet
again a government agency being
repudiated being reprimanded for
targeting someone based on their faith
and so I think what we see here is that
you know turns out the First Amendment
is pretty is pretty is pretty
straightforward the First Amendment is
pretty explicit pretty clear it says
that you have free exercise of religion
and it cannot be abridged it cannot be
infringed that's what the First
Amendment says
it's it's it's not written in coded
language it's not written in invisible
ink you don't need a secret decoder to
rate it read it it's right there you
have freedom of religion in this country
and I think what that means is that the
left
eventually what they're gonna realize
that you know there really is no getting
around that obviously they want to get
rid of religious liberty but as long as
the First Amendment exists there's
there's just no way they can do it so I
think for the left for progressives
their only option in the end is gonna it
will their only option really is to
revoke the First Amendment is to get rid
of it repeal it we're certainly not at a
place yet where they're gonna start
openly advocating for that but I would
predict that in 10-15 years that's going
to be a mainstream view on the left that
at the very not repeal the entire First
Amendment but to take religion out of
the First Amendment because their
argument is is that is that religion is
not a legitimate thing in the first
place
religion is superstition even though as
I established earlier we they have their
own religion in their own faith-based
views but that's their that's their
point of view religion is just not it's
an oppressive institution it's not
legitimate it shouldn't be in there so I
would expect that eventually 10 to 15
years maybe earlier you're gonna find
it's gonna be a mainstream view on the
left that freedom of religion must be
taken out of the First Amendment because
that's the only way for them to
ultimately achieve their goals here but
in the meantime let's celebrate some
Kelvin Cochran and his great great
victory well deserved thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed